BUT THIS TIME, IT WAS ALEX De
BRINCAT.
THE OTHER GET BACK,
GOOD RECOVERY BY GUSTAFSSON.
DROPS IT TO KANE AND TRIED TO BG
ANNOUNCEMENT DO, TALK TO
NKINEN.
>> I DON'T THINKMAYBE THAT'S ON
NOW WE'RE TALKING RIGHT THERE.
>>WAS STRALMAN WHO
MADE THE PLAY, PAT.
THE STICK
GOSTISBEHERE GETS DID IN THE
ZONE.
PASS WAS
GOING AND WILL LEAVE THE MIDDLE
OF THE ICE.
DOWN LOW WITH IT
BOYD.
THE COYOTES CLEAR JUST AS THE
PENALTY EXPIRES.
ANTHAT ONE IS UPSTAIRS.
>> A JONES, IN THE MIDDLE.
HE WAS JUST ON THE VERGE, PATRI.
JONES TO KANE.
NETSAVE MADE BY LANKINEN.
KANE.
STROME
FRONT,AND IT'S AHAWKS WILL GO T.
IN THE MIDDLE.
DI GOSTISBEHERE DROPS IT BACK.
ABSOLUTE WIDE OPEN NET BUT HOW
SCHMALTZ.